he actually built the lander analytics
server from scratch
so with that
jared
join us all right hi folks you saw me
earlier
uh i'm here to talk about gis and r
particularly how i'm going to use
geographic information systems
so to do that we have to talk about maps
and yes i know this is a globe but we
are going to flatten it out into a map
we're going to project it downward and
we'll look at it in a 2d surface
and when you're talking about gis it's
all about relations
and these are relations between
points lines and polygons and they're
multiversions multi-lines multi-points
multi-polygons it's all about how they
relate to each other
so today's goals
we're going to do a number of things
today
we are going to draw maps with different
packages
we are going to compute relations
specifically between points and polygons
and we are going to solve a fun mapping
puzzle
so let's start with maps we're going to
make maps with a bunch of different
packages
to do that we need data
and for our data we're going to look at
citibike because we all know how much i
love talking about the city
we're going to make specifically two
types of maps plotting actual individual
city bike stations
and making
heat maps for counts of stations in
different neighborhoods
so first up we need the city bike data
now this data is old the system is
actually much bigger now than it was
when i pulled this data so don't just go
by this but it's good for example and
the data came as a plain old csv
latitude and longitude or stored as
column so i need to read it in then i
need to convert it to an sf object and i
never remember is it longitude and
latitude or latitude and longitude so i
try both ways and plot it and see if i'm
in the middle of the ocean or see if i'm
in new york city
and we set the crs to be 4326 to tell it
that we're using lat long
and this is what it looks like it's an
sf object which is essentially a table
with more information
it tells us that there are 813 features
and it took me forever to realize that a
feature is not a column but it's a row
and 18 fields that made sense that that
would be a column we get a bounding box
which is the rectangle that fits all the
data and the geodetic crs is wgs 84
which is just lat long which we already
said earlier they just use different
names
now it's a table so we're not seeing all
the columns so if i select just a few
columns the geometry column whether it's
called geometry or not always gets
selected along it's sticky so even
though you can see i use a regular d
plier select it included the geometry
column for me
that's our station data we also need new
york city neighborhood data
and a lot of people think new york city
neighborhoods can be controversial like
does chelsea stop at 6th avenue or 5th
avenue there's debate
there is no debate new york city tells
us exactly where neighborhoods start and
stop
they provide this as a geo json file
which means that all the geometric
information is already in there we don't
need to convert it to sf we use the read
sf function to read it in this can read
in shape files geo json other files even
database connections
and here is our neighborhood file you'll
see before our geometry was point
geometry as individual points on a map
here there are multi polygons a multi
polygon is when you could have two
disjoint polygons that are one unit
that's why it's called a multi-polygon
but for the most part they're probably
regular polygons with like a few
multi-polygons
so first we will plot using base
plotting and the sf package
and if you just say plot of docs
it makes a separate plot for each column
of data it gets the x and y from the
geometry column and then color codes it
according to a specific column and it
makes a small multiple for free you
don't need to do anything cool
but if we just want a plain simple xy
plot we just selected the geometry
column
and we get this dot matrix plot
cool looks nice you can tell it's
manhattan and brooklyn and queens and
some other stuff we'll talk about
but let's say we want to plot this on
top of our neighborhoods
well first we plot the neighborhoods by
taking our nyc data getting the geometry
column plotting it and then we call plot
on top of the docs and we say add equals
true this is base graphics that's adding
a layer on top of the previous existing
plot and we're color and we're just
setting the color to be blue and you can
see all these dots across the hudson
river that's jersey city because they
expanded the program a few years ago
into jersey
we could do more base plotting but we
won't because we'll turn straight to
ggplot the old standby that can plot
anything so first up we're just going to
plot the dots
and we see here we call ggplot give it
the sf object then we say geom sf
it automatically knows go to the
geometry column and plot whatever it is
if it's points draw points if it's a
polygon drop polygons it does it all
automatically i'm using chord sf just to
make the boundaries look right and you
can vaguely make out new york city here
but i want to plot this on top of the
neighborhoods like i just did so we're
going to just add another layer here and
we will say gmsf twice
the first time we say data equals the
nyc data that gives us the neighborhoods
the polygons and the second time we say
gmsf which uses the default docs from
the ggplot call now it looks a lot nicer
but it does still look like it's from
the 80s
we will fix that a little bit but before
we can fix that we have to answer the
question how many docks are in each
neighborhood
this has many steps to it we first need
to do a spatial join to figure out which
docs are in which neighborhoods we then
need to just compute a count of each
neighborhood and then create a plot
which is a choropleth
so first the spatial join which docs are
in which neighborhoods
so we take the docs data frame we select
a couple columns out of there and then
we st join it into the nyc data set this
is a special type of join it is when one
of the row or the left table matches one
row of the right table based on a
spatial relationship
we can define that spatial relationship
with the join column here i'm using st
intersects which is sort of a catch-all
if the point is touching the polygon the
point is overlapping the polygon the
point is crossing the polygon is that
there's any sort of like physical
relationship with them it captures it
and i'm doing left equals false because
i don't want a left joint i want an
inner join so i'm only getting docs that
are represented in new york city
neighborhoods to get rid of all the ones
in jersey
so this is what it looks like since we
joined it on the docs data frame on the
left we have the geometry points from
there and you can see we now have each
neighborhood each dock is in
so now i want to do a count so i just
use regular d plier code and i first
drop the drop the geometry because
things go faster then i just do count of
the neighborhood name and then i right
join it back into the nyc data so i can
have this count column joined in with
the polygon data and we see it right
here we see that there are 22 docks in
astoria 23 in battery park 21 in bedford
so on and so forth it's one row per
neighborhood so let's plot it with
ggplot
we call yet again gmsf but this time we
passed it a polygon sf that has a count
column and we say aes fill equals n the
count column and it colors it for us
jersey city is gone and we see that
lighter blue means more docks
that's awesome
but i want to move on to other ways to
map and we have two more methods the
first is going to be tmap we're getting
a little fancier here
with tmap you pass the sf object to tm
shape that defines the layer that you'll
be working with and since i want to draw
dots i then call tm dots and this plots
the geometry column as dots
if i want the neighborhoods
i call tm shape of the neighborhood data
set
and then tm polygons i then change the
layer with tm shape again to use docs
and plot tm dots to get the dots on top
of the polygons
you build it up iteratively much like
ggplot
and if you want a coropluff
you do tm shape of another dataframe and
you can do tm tm polygons but you say
call for color equals the column n in
quotes and that colors in for you
but i want to turn to my favorite
mapping package leaflet
tm plot can do interactive but leaflet
excels at it i'm much i'm a much bigger
fan of leaflet so if leaflet you say
leaflet and here i'm giving an element
id you don't need to do that
interactively but if you're using our
markdown it makes things a lot better
i say add tiles and that gives me this
background the base plot
it looks like google maps but it's
actually open street maps and you can
zoom in you can pan around i won't but
it's on my website you could click and
drag around and add circles i say data
equals docs
if i pass it an sf object it just knows
how to get latitude and longitude and it
plots it
if you want the polygons underneath the
dots you say add polygons give it the
polygon data frame then add circles give
it the dots data frame and you can see
here i added an argument pop-up equals
tilde and t-name if you click on a
polygon it pops up with a neighborhood
name same with the circles if you click
a circle it pops up with a station name
you do tilde bear column name
so the problem with using leaflet
generally is that it doesn't scale to
large data so we have leaf gl this uses
webgl and when you do that you can plot
hundreds of thousands of points in a few
seconds
here i did the same thing instead of add
polygons i did add gl polygons now the
problem with gl polygons it doesn't like
multi-polygons so you need to cast it
into a regular polygon first
and now when you do the pop-up
there's no consistency you no longer do
tilde column name you give the column
name in quotes because different people
wrote different packages and they have
no consistency but it's nice it gets the
job done let's go ahead and plot a
coropluff
if i use regular leaflet i have to first
create a color palette by mapping it to
the domain of the counts and then i have
to call add polygons and say fill color
it's a whole thing i don't like it it's
a huge pain i'm just gonna skip this
slide and move on to a better slide okay
before i get into the embedded thing
though i said well maybe i could zoom in
on the plot and you zoom in by saying
set view i say set view give it the
center of the view with longitude and
latitude and i set my view my zoom at
11.
the default is 10 it can go from 1 to
15. this is a little bit easier to read
but it's still hard to read that
choropleth right it's hard to make out
the colors it's a little too busy
so i thought well let's change the base
map
by changing the base map from
openstreetmaps to cartodb voyager it's a
little simpler the background is a
little plainer and the way i did that
was i switched from ad tiles to ad
provider tiles
now the version of leaflet on cran does
not work with quarto so i had to go make
a pull request which has not been
reviewed yet to fix it and tell it where
to download javascript files it works
hopefully they'll get merged into crayon
or hopefully quartz will get fixed or
one of the others but you can see it's a
little bit simpler of a map here it's
still hard to read right and i still
have to define the palette myself
so i'm going to turn back to leaf gl
when you use leaf gl and use ad gl
polygons you give it the column you want
to control the color as a quote as in
quotes and it figures out the color
palette for you and in my opinion is
using much more attractive colors than
the one i had selected earlier yes i
selected the colors before and i chose
poorly
ad gl polygons chose wisely and i think
this is much easier to read i'm much
happier about this
and if you want to add points on top of
a choropleth you just say add gl points
on top of the previously existing
polygons and that's it you build it up
iteratively layer by layer just like you
would ggplot
so far i've been making my choropleths
by neighborhood which are these
arbitrarily defined boundaries based on
some bureaucrat in the city
so instead i want to use hex bins i want
to bin up my data into small hexagons
and plot the density of those hexagons
now the question is how do i get these
points into hexagons
thankfully there is a system called h3
put up by uber which is exposed to us by
the h3 jsr package and this maps any
point on the earth to a hexagon and the
map is in the whole earth has been
mapped to 15 layers of hexagons from
really really tiny to really really big
so all i have to do is give it my
geometry column and it maps it to an h3
it gives me a specific h3 index and then
i'm able to convert that h3 index back
into a polygon
so now i can make a choropleth based on
the polygons i simply do a count on that
and tells me everything i'm all done how
nice and simple is that i know i went
through the side really quickly but the
code's all up there you can check it out
nice easy way to do it and it's really
big help having these h3 hexagons that
has managed to compute my gis processing
when i'm actually doing real statistics
on this by about a hundred fold in speed
it's made a big difference
and leaflet has all sorts of other cool
features we could take a look at
right here i added just a few things
you'll notice on the top upper right
corner there's a little measuring tool
if you click that it's an interactive
tool where you can measure the distance
between different points on the map
you can even make a little polygon to
measure the distance between the
polygons
on the upper left i added a logo and
then you'll see this function at add
mouse coordinates
you can't see it here but if i were to
move my mouse around on there it would
show you the latitude and longitude of
wherever your mouse is pointing
but let's say you don't want this boring
map as your background you want a
satellite view
well we use add provider tiles yet again
and this time i'm saying
use esri world imagery which provides 15
layers of zoom of satellite imagery of
the earth
but you'll notice i also have cartodb up
there
and there's a radio button i'm able to
flip between the different maps if i
click that radio button i can switch to
openstreetmaps or back to esri satellite
view
i can also
turn on and off my docs points or my
hexagons i have now not allowed the user
to have full control over their map and
say take away this layer switch to this
map all this control all of just a few
lines of code so simple for me to make
so that's a lot of lies to make
different plots so far we've done the
spatial join we have made a bunch of
different plots so now it's time to play
a game
and when i finish the talk i actually
wrote my talk ahead of time about a
month ago the most popular game going
around was wordle
no you can't play wordle gis but you can
play wordle
this is a wordle clone where
they show you the outline of a country
and you have to guess what the country
is
and every time you get a wrong guess
they tell you the distance to the
correct country and it's measured from
the center of the wrong guest to the
center of the correct country and they
tell you which direction generally north
east or south or southwest they give you
the general direction of where you're
going so
i have no clue what country this is
so i just started guessing iceland i was
13 000 kilometers away sierra leone 7
000 kilometers lesotho 3000 kilometers
i'm getting closer but i can't find this
place i have no clue where it is so i
said you know what i'm going to
triangulate this
so i obviously put the data into a
typical in r
and then all i said i had to do is i
need to find the centers of these
countries because remember wordle tells
you the distance from center to center
so i pull out our natural earth which
provides polygons for every country on
earth
right i make sure it's an sf object so
it comes as an sp which is the old way
of doing gis and r
i transform it into lat long then i
inner join with my three guesses just
get the three of them
and then i find the centers of those
three countries by calling st centroid
and that gives me the centers of those
countries
and i can plot them on a map
and i plotted both the polygon of the
countries and the centers and if you
were to zoom in on this map you'll see
that the polygons don't exactly match
openstreetmap they're using different
boundaries for the countries which by
the way is a huge problem when you're
doing gis if you think oh look at this
point that's outside outside the
maritime borders for a country but it's
really inside those maritime borders
that's an international incident
so you got to be kind of careful with
this stuff
all right so our goal now is to
triangulate the idea is we take each of
these dots and we draw a circle of the
given radius around them and where those
three circles intersect is our correct
country right
so
i draw a buffer around each of these
countries
i have the distances in kilometers i
multiply by a thousand to get meters and
i pass that to st buffer
now in the past if you wanted to draw a
buffer around a polygon
you needed to make a projection a local
projection into a meters projection
because latitude a longitude is angles
from around the earth and it messes
things up but thanks to google we have
spherical geometry and we have the s2
package which is turned on by default by
sf now so when i say give me a buffer of
13 000 kilometers it gives me a 13 000
kilometer circle around that point i
don't need to worry about projections
anymore this is groundbreaking
but when you call st buffer it actually
gives you a filled in circle
i want the outside of the circle so i
cast it to a line string which just
gives me the ring the outside of the
circle
and when i plot this i get this
now i know a lot of you're thinking
those don't look like circles
that's because of the shape of the earth
you see the blue circle looks like a
circle right
the yellow one
is elongated because the earth is it's
sphere it's a bad sphere right
let's talk about that purple circle
that's around iceland now remember
iceland i was 13 000 kilometers away and
it's near the pole it's that horizontal
line in the back that's actually not on
the front of the globe that's going
around the back of the globe but we're
just not plotting it well so we can
ignore that all right just ignore that
little thing don't pay attention to that
now theoretically where our three
circles intersect that's our answer
i could have just zoomed in and found my
place but no i want to do the math
so i take my circles and i call st
intersection
that tells me all the points where these
circles intersect and remember by
triangulation two circles will intersect
in two places but three circles will
only intersect in that one place
assuming they all have different radii
right so i filter again a regular d
plier verb and i filter in when there's
only
three overlaps or more and i get this
location 3.48 negative
54.73 that's my location so let's plot
it and see what's there
when you plot that i had to add tiles
it's ocean
i then added my circles for overlaps and
it was
so tiny this little place actually i had
to create a 100 kilometer search buffer
around this thing because i couldn't
find it
it was bouvet island
it is so small it is not in natural
earth they don't keep track of it
so i said what is on this island so i
switched to satellite view there's
nothing there
it is an uninhabited nature reserve in
the middle of the south atlantic owned
by norway
i don't know how it got there but it's
there i don't know why that's in the
game i don't even know how they got it
in the game but if it wasn't for gis and
triangulation i would have failed that
day and it would have broke my streak
so thanks to mapping and gis i got it
so we did a lot of stuff really fast
today we did a lot of different things
so just what we learned today
we learned about sf objects or just
tibbles of extra geometry information
and the sf package has almost all the
gis operations you want but there's more
operations in lw geom and h3jsr and
geodist and other packages as well
st join is the real workhorse of spatial
analytics you're always doing spatial
drawings all the time it's really
powerful and you can make maps of
ggplot2 or team map or my favorite
leaflet
it's all about finding these
relationships between the points lines
and polygons it's all points lines and
polygons and how they go together
so thank you very much
you